[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend
schmuddelig fing es an mit Online
Glücksspiel und Pornos und geendet ist
es in dem wohl größten Fall von
Wirtschaftskriminalität in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik dazwischen
lagen Jahre in denen das Unternehmen
Wirecard gefeiert wurde in Politik
Medien und Finanzwelt es glänzte wieder
Schatz im Silbersee verdrängte die
Commerzbank aus dem Dax der Aktienkurs
stieg und stieg von all dem ist nichts
mehr übrig
zurückbleiben Milliardenschäden
geprellte Anleger und hochnotpeinliche
Fragen an Bankenaufsicht
Wirtschaftsprüfer und regierende heute
war Prozessauftakt in München Petra
Neubauer berichtet
spektakulär ist zu vieles an diesem
Prozess etwa der Verhandlungsort im
unterirdischen hochsicherheitssaal auf
dem Gelände der JVA Stadelheim
spektakulär auch seine Geschichte markus
Braun einst gefeierte Chef von Wirecard
und nun mit zwei ehemaligen Managern auf
der Anklagebank
dem Angeschuldigten braun werfen wir den
bandenmäßigen gewerbsmäßigen Betrug vor
mag Manipulation und Treue und
Bilanzfälschung auch als unrichtige
Darstellung bezeichnet vor mit Wirecard
dürften schon viele zu tun gehabt haben
hinter bargeldlosen Zahlungen steckte
oft der Finanzdienstleister aus Aschheim
da Warrior Card für die Transaktionen
aber nicht in allen Ländern Lizenzen
hatte arbeitete das Unternehmen
international mit Drittanbietern
zusammen ein komplexes schwer zu
durchschauendes Geflecht
Wirecard wird zum Börsenliebling schafft
es in den Dachs bis im Juni 2020 das
Bild zerbricht markus Braun muss bekannt
geben dass 1,9 Milliarden Euro fehlen
angeblich Geld aus dem Asiengeschäft
doch laut Anklage war alles nur
vorgetäuscht mit dem Ziel ein
Unternehmen das längst nicht so
erfolgreich war wie es sich nach außen
hin gerne dargestellt hat erfolgreicher
da stehen zu lassen so habe Wirecard
immer wieder
wir Kredite kommen wollen markus Braun
äußerlich unverändert und typisch mit
dunklem Rolli sieht sich als Opfer
betrogen von ehemaligen Kollegen wie dem
untergetauchten Jan marschalek dieser
gilt für viele als Schlüsselfigur des
Skandals aber so ein
riesenwirtschaftskandal kann nicht eine
alleine machen allein das Schreiben der
gefällten Rechnungen das dauert Monate
das kann an markus Braun nicht vorbei
gegangen sein entweder er ist der aller
dümmste CEO der Wirtschaftsgeschichte
oder aber er lügt uns hier weiterhin
etwas vor noch ist unklar ob sich markus
Braun im Prozess äußern wird schriftlich
erklären seine Verteidiger dr markus
Braun war in die Machenschaften die
ausschließlich der Veruntreuung von
Geldern der Wirecard AG dienten nicht
involviert und hatte hiervon auch keine
Kenntnis
so spektakulär die Milliarden Pleite von
Wirecard war so komplex dürfte die
Aufarbeitung des ganzen werden der
Prozess ist dabei nur ein Baustein die
Frage ob die Manager den Betrug zu
verantworten haben das wird der Prozess
am Ende dann feststellen aber wir werden
es sehr viele Jahre natürlich mit diesem
Prozess noch zu tun haben bzw auch mit
den Folgen des Prozesses die
Kleinaktionäre die wollen natürlich
irgendwann auch Ihr Geld zurück und das
wird in diesem Prozess nicht geklärt
rund fünf Stunden braucht die
Staatsanwaltschaft für die Verlesung der
Anklage kurz danach endet der Prozesstag
es werden noch viele folgen bislang gibt
es hundert Termine
er war der erste Politiker der hier in
Deutschland vor Wirecard gewarnt hatte
Fabio demasi schon dass sie uns heute
Abend zugeschaltet sind guten Abend
guten Frau sie gehörten zu jedem
Parlamentariern die echte Finanzexperten
sind sie saßen für die Linke im
Bundestag und sich da in diese Materie
tief eingegraben hatten und in diesem
Untersuchungsausschuss dann auch eine
führende Rolle spielten rückblickend sie
waren ja ziemlich allein am Anfang da
als Mana woher kam dieser Hype diese
irre witzige Begeisterung für dieses
eine Unternehmen die erklären Sie sich
das
ich glaube das ist ein Stück weit das
Internet das ist ein Fenster in die
Zukunft gewesen Wirecard dass man
irgendwie gesagt hat die machen
irgendwas mit Internet die wickelnder
Zahlungen ab und viele Politiker wollen
natürlich dann bei so einem innovativen
Startup auf dem roten Teppich stehen und
das Unternehmen hatte auch ein großes
politisches Netzwerk das haben sie
nämlich gut gepflegt
in höchste Kreise sozusagen
absolut ein Beispiel der CEO markus
Braun der ist auf der Anklagebank sitzt
der war Chefberater das ehemaligen
österreichischen Bundeskanzler Sebastian
Kurz und auch in Deutschland gab es
zahlreiche Kontakte zu Spitzenpolitik
dann könnte man noch sagen gut Politiker
die sind nicht alle dann auch mit
Finanzen so vertraut und können alle
Bilanzen solche Konzerne lesen oder sich
in Finanzkriminalität einarbeiten aber
ein Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft eine
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft wie wie
eine oder die BaFin die Bankenaufsicht
die müssten das doch eigentlich können
und die bleiben immer noch blind selbst
also schon erste Presseberichte kam
ja das war tatsächlich absurd die
Wirtschaftsprüfer von die haben
jahrelang da abschlüssetestiert die
haben nie überprüft ob zum Beispiel 1,9
Milliarden Euro ein Drittel der
Bilanzsumme auf irgendwelchen dubiosen
Treuhand konnten liegen sind haben das
nicht wirklich überprüft bis zum Ende
und die Finanzaufsicht war von die hatte
überhaupt nur fünf Personen mit
Wirtschaftsprüfer Examen ich sag immer
dass es so wie als wenn man jetzt sagen
würde der ADAC macht nach dem
Oktoberfest die Alkoholkontrolle am
Ortgang und die Polizei kann das gar
nicht oder ist gar nicht dafür zuständig
das kann natürlich nicht gut gehen das
gibt Interessenkonflikte und jetzt sagt
welche welche Lehren ziehen wir daraus
was müsste sich strukturell ändern ist
da so ein Punkt dass man sagt
staatlicherseits sind eigentlich nicht
genügend Fachleute da und auf der
Wirtschaftsseite da wo das große Geld
verdient wird da sitzen dann die die
clever ist
ja das ist natürlich ein fundamentales
Problem dass mittlerweile die
talentiertes Leute am Finanzmarkt die
kriegen natürlich riesen Gehälter bei
Banken und anderen Institutionen und
gehen dorthin ich glaube dennoch es gibt
auch sehr gute Beamte in Deutschland es
gibt auch Leute die großen Anstand große
Integrität haben wir sehen das zum
Beispiel in den ganzen cum-ex-verfahren
mit einer Staatsanwältin die da sehr
engagiert ist das Problem ist glaube ich
einfach dass unsere Behörden nicht so
aufgestellt sind wie sie sein müssten
zum Beispiel bei der Bekämpfung von
Geldwäsche wir haben diese Debatten
immer wieder jetzt auch zum Beispiel wo
keine Krieg wenn es um die Yachten von
Oligarchen geht und wir manchmal gar
nicht wissen wenige gehören und das
rechte sich eben auch bei Wirecard weil
Wirecard war im Kern eine große
Geldanlage
sie haben ja die Vermutung geäußert dass
da nicht nur
Mafiosis Geld gewaschen haben sondern
dass dieses Unternehmen auch von
Geheimdiensten in irgendeiner Form
benutzt wurde
das liegt zumindest sehr nah sehen sie
nur mal zwei drei kleine Beispiele zu
nennen Jan masalic der flüchtige wirecut
Manager der hatte Kontakt mit einem
ehemaligen deutschen
geheimdienstkoordinator ein weiterer
ehemaliger deutscher Geheimdienst
Koordinator Kanzler arbeitete direkt vor
Wirecard hatte Kontakt zu einem
russischen
Generalkonsul der in Österreich bereits
der Spionage bezüchtigt wurde er hatte
Kontakt zu einem lang hohen ehemaligen
er traf sich mit Richard granell dem
ehemaligen Botschafter von Donald Trump
und obwohl es Ermittlungsverfahren 2015
gab wo er direkt unüber Beschuldigter
war mit einer Razzia wegen
Zahlungsabwicklung im Bereich Online
Glücksspiel und Geldwäsche hat wurde das
Verfahren eingestellt um kurze Zeit
später ist groß in den USA Prepaid
Karten eingestiegen also ein Bereich der
gerade zu exponiert ist für Geldwäsche
das ist doch alles sehr seltsam
da ist dann vielleicht dem ein oder
anderen ist gar nicht so unrecht wenn
der Mann da bleibt wo er ist nämlich
irgendwo im Untergrund in Russland
mutmaßlich
wenn mein Eindruck ist dass viele Leute
auch eine Sicherheitsbehörden doch recht
zufrieden sind wenn Herr masalik
wegbleibt auch für Herrn Braun ist das
übrigens ganz sinnvoll weil dann kann er
vor Gericht so tun wer es sei ja einfach
nur der dümmste hier auch Deutschlands
gewesen und der auch
Opfer von Jan masalic das glaube ich ihm
natürlich nicht denn markus Braun hat
selbst noch persönlich die letzte
Liquidität im Unternehmen freigezeichnet
er war aus meiner Sicht Kopf der Bande
aber das ist jetzt eben Aufgabe von
Staatsanwalt und Staatsanwältin und
Gerichten das nachzudenken das wird ein
langer Prozess hätte mal sie danke für
das Gespräch
anderes Thema verurteilt und
hingerichtet wegen Kriegsführung gegen
Gott so begründet das iranische Regime
das ist heute einen 23-jährigen getötet
hat hatte ein Demonstrationen
teilgenommen gestorben sind in diesem
Freiheitskampf schon viele aber seit
Beginn dieser Protestwelle ist er der
erste der offiziell hingerichtet wird
wer sich gegen das Regime auflehnt führt
Krieg gegen Gott das ist die Botschaft
mit der diese Diktatur die Bevölkerung
einschüchtern will und es steht zu
befürchten dass es noch viele weitere
Hinrichtungen geben wird sehr kleiner
Ullmann über die Lage in ihrer
[Musik]
Harry wurde nur 23 Jahre alt heute wurde
der Iraner gehängt nach einem
showprozess am 20 November wurde shahari
fürs blockieren einer Straße und
angebliche verletzen eines milizisten
zum Tode verurteilt die Regime Treue
iranische Nachrichtenagentur misan
bestätigte Hinrichtung heute seine
Familie erfährt es am Nachmittag
die Menschenverachtung des iranischen
Regimes ist grenzenlos maschinischer
Kari wurde in einem perfiden
Schnellverfahren abgeurteilt und
hingerichtet weil er anderer Meinung als
das Regime war
in dieser Woche hier ein Video aus
gorvey gab es einen dreitägigen
Generalstreik erstmals
schichtübergreifend eine wesentliche
Entwicklung das auch die Unterstützung
in der Bevölkerung sehr groß ist sowohl
beispielsweise unter dem traditionellen
basaris die bis dato ja auch eher als
traditionell wahrgenommen wurden und als
Unterstützungsbasis des Regimes aber der
unmittelbevölkerung ist sehr sehr groß
die Hartnäckigkeit ist sehr groß und wir
haben in meinen Augen diese Woche einen
qualitativen Schritt nach vorne gesehen
innerhalb dieses revolutionären
Prozesses beim gestrigen vorläufigen
Höhepunkt am Tag der Studierenden hält
Präsident Ibrahim Reich sie vor
systemfreund Studenten eine Hassrede
gegen die USA während an vielen Unis im
Land die Studenten und dozieren der auf
die Straße gehen um für mehr Rechte zu
protestieren bis in den Abend gibt es
Proteste in einem Dutzend Städten und
erstmals zentral auf dem Platz der
Freiheit Asad
die Stadtverwaltung lässt das Licht
löschen so ist nicht erkennbar wie viele
gekommen sind wer verwundet oder gar
getötet wurde Schüsse sind zu hören die
Paramilitärs gehen auch in der Stadt
bomarhand brutal vor wie dieses
twitter-video zeigt
es wie Menschenrechtsorganisation schon
zurecht in meinen Augen gewarnt haben
besteht tatsächlich die Gefahr dass wenn
die das Regime die Proteste unter
Kontrolle bringt oder aber die
internationale Aufmerksamkeit auf die
Proteste in Iran wegfallen es zu
Massaker ähnlichen Maßnahmen kommen kann
die Proteste im Iran gehen weiter auch
heute im Gefängnis haben mindestens 11
zum Tode verurteilte Demonstranten und
viele weitere ohne dass ihre Angehörigen
die vor dem Gefängnis warten irgendetwas
ausrichten könnten
und jetzt gibt es erstmal andere
Nachrichten Heinz und dazu next eine die
in den USA für große Erleichterung sorgt
die US-Profi Basketballerinnen Brittney
griner die in Russland inhaftiert war
ist wieder frei sie wurde gegen den
russischen Waffenhändler Viktor Booth
ausgetauscht
US-Präsident beiden verkündete die
Freilassung griner befindet sich derzeit
auf dem Flug zurück in die USA die
32-Jährige Basketball Olympiasiegerin
war in Russland unter dem Vorwurf des
Drogenbesitzes zu einer neunjährigen
Haftstrafe verurteilt worden
auch der frühere Sowjet-Offizier gut ist
wieder zurück in Russland 2012 war gegen
ihn in den USA eine 25-jährige
Gefängnisstrafe wegen terrorvorwürfen
verhängt worden
Bund und Länder haben die letzten Hürden
zur Einführung eines bundesweit gültigen
Nahverkehrstickets beseitigt die Kosten
sollen 2023 je zur Hälfte getragen
werden und das Kanzler scholz sagte nach
Beratungen mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten das
deutschlandticket werde jetzt kommen der
genaue Starttermin für das 49 Euro
Ticket ist noch unklar außerdem
verständigten sich Bund und Länder auf
letzte Details eines härtefallfonds für
Unternehmen in der Wirtschaftskrise
nach der groß angelegten Anti-Terror
Razzia gegen die reichsbürgerszene
untersuchen die Ermittlungsbehörden
Spuren zum möglichen weiteren
Verdächtigen auch die Frage ob es
weitere versteckte Waffen gibt wird
geprüft wegen mutmaßlicher Vorbereitung
zu einem Umsturz sind seit gestern 23
Personen in Untersuchungshaft genommen
worden
das Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz hat
nach dem zweiten bundesweiten warentag
eine erste positive Bilanz gezogen
demnach habe das System gut funktioniert
dennoch gäbe es an der ein oder anderen
Stelle Verbesserungsbedarf
die Behörde hatte wie angekündigt um 11
Uhr landesweite probewarnung ausgelöst
viele Handys schrillten laut
sirenenholten und im Radio und TV gab es
waren Informationen mit der probewarnung
sollte herausgefunden werden wie viele
Menschen im Ernstfall erreicht würden
was ist bedeutet mitten in der
Europäischen Union zu leben fühlt man ja
besonders beim grenzenlosen Reisen
einfach mal rüber nach Frankreich ohne
Schlagbäume ohne Passkontrolle die
Jüngeren haben erst in der Pandemie noch
mal nachfüllen können wie das früher war
mit Autoschlangen vor den Grenzen
Schengenabkommen gilt als Meilenstein
der europäischen Integration manche
Staaten wollten das für sich nie wie
Großbritannien aber für die meisten
EU-Mitglieder ist es nicht nur ein
Wirtschaftsfaktor sondern auch eine
Prestigefrage ob man dazu gehört oder
nicht
insofern war das für Bulgarien und
Rumänien heute ein schmerzlicher Tag
Kroatien darf rein sie nicht hintergrund
ist die flüchtlingsdebatte die ja schon
so oft die Europäische Union entzweigt
hat Florian neuhahn berichtet
es ist kalt aber wenigstens haben sie
seit kurzem diese Zelte ein Lager mitten
auf dem Gehweg es sind geflüchtete um
die Europa sich nicht kümmern will
mitten in Europas Hauptstadt eine Brücke
über dem Kanal von Brüssel seit Monaten
warten Sie hier auf die Chance Asyl
überhaupt zu beantragen geflohen aus
Afghanistan gestrandet im Brüsseler
Behörden Chaos
so etwas das hätte ich nie erwartet aber
so Gott will hoffentlich wird es gut
Belgien kommt nach eigener Aussage nicht
hinterher mit dem Andrang dass dabei
solche Bilder entstehen nimmt man wohl
in Kauf und schlägt derweil quasi
nebenan in diesem Glaskästen von Brüssel
Alarm
die Realität ist dass der Zustrom in
unser Land extrem hoch ist wir haben
solche Zahlen seit 2015 nicht mehr
gesehen und wir müssen an einer besseren
Verteilung und mehr Solidarität zwischen
den Mitgliedstaaten arbeiten
die Verteilung von geflüchteten schon
2015 stieß Europa da angrenzen jetzt
fällt das Thema Ihnen wieder auf die
Füße Mitten als hier beim Treffen der
Innenminister eigentlich etwas anderes
zur Abstimmung steht die Erweiterung des
sogenannten Schengenraums der Zone in
der Europäer sich ohne Grenzkontrollen
bewegen dürfen nach Jahren der
Verhandlung sollen nun Kroatien
Bulgarien und Rumänien aufgenommen
werden bei Kroatien ist man sich einig
doch vor allem Österreich sperrt sich
gegen die Aufnahme von Rumänien und
Bulgarien das Argument es kommen gerade
zu viele Flüchtlinge wir haben in
Österreich in diesem Jahr über 100.000
illegale Grenzübertritte davon sind
75000 nicht registriert
das eine Indiz oder der eine Hinweis
dass das System nicht funktioniert an
dieser Stelle das ist ein Veto das viele
hier enttäuscht nicht nur die beiden
betroffenen Staaten
es gab Kriterien die Sie zu erfüllen
hatten alle drei haben sie gleichermaßen
erfüllt dann wäre es nur folgerichtig
gewesen dann auch allen Staaten
gleichermaßen das zu gewähren
wenn wir einig sind in der Europäischen
Union dann sind wir stark können so viel
erreichen in diesem Moment bei der
Aufnahme von Rumänien und Bulgarien aber
sind wir nicht einig das macht uns sehr
schwach und es macht mich traurig
und so sind es die geflüchteten die
Europa mal wieder streiten lassen von
ihrem Zeltlager in Brüssel aus schauen
Sie auf die asylantragstelle oben weht
die Europa Fahne die Farben längst
verblasst
für Vladimir putinen muss es eine
äußerst unangenehme Entwicklung sein
dass es immer häufiger Explosionen und
Einschläge auch auf russischem Boden
gibt heute in der Grenzstadt Belgorod
oder zuletzt auf zwei Militärflughäfen
von denen aus Russland Angriffe auf die
Ukraine fliegt für das Selbstbild eines
unverletzlichen Reiches sind das
unangenehme Nadelstiche der Wahl gehen
die russischen Angriffe auf die Ukraine
weiter unsere Reporter Hannah Hebestreit
war heute in einer Kinderklinik in mir
westlich von Kiew
Klinikdirektor juridorf hoppoli führt
uns in den Atomschutzbunker aus der Zeit
des Kalten Krieges
hier müssen seine Patienten und Kollegen
Schutz suchen wenn Russland wieder
Raketen Richtung schiete mir in der
zentral Ukraine abfeuert
für 125 Menschen manchmal müssen wir
aber bis zu 250 Patienten hier
unterbringen das ist natürlich für alle
dann sehr beklemmend
mascha ist aus einer russisch besetzten
Region im Osten der Ukraine hierher
geflüchtet ihr Mann kämpft an der Front
sie selbst muss sogar im Krankenhaus um
das Leben ihres neugeborenen Sohnes
bange
in den Keller keiner wusste was passiert
ich hatte große Angst wegen meines Babys
ich mache mir um ihn viel mehr Sorgen
als um mich selbst ich hoffe dass das
bald vorbei ist
ihre Ärztin erlebt auf der
Geburtenstation oft unmittelbar die
Folgen von Russlands
angriffskriegs und weil sie ihre Heimat
verlassen mussten viele Babys kommen
früher auf die Welt und oft mit deutlich
weniger Gewicht als gut für sie ist
Pflegekräfte und Mediziner kämpfen oft
einen harten Kampf um jedes Leben das
auf die Welt kommt und kaum stark genug
ist fürs Überleben
gespendete medizinische Geräte aus dem
Ausland sind dabei eine wichtige Hilfe
der parat dieses Gerät haben wir aus
Deutschland bekommen dafür bin ich sehr
dankbar die Neugeborenen erholen sich in
diesen Geräten schneller als in unseren
alten Apparaten
auch bei Operationen kommen moderne
Beatmungsgeräte aus Deutschland zum
Einsatz trotzdem können sich die
Arbeitsbedingungen der Chirurgen von
einem Augenblick auf den anderen ändern
wir hatten schon mitten in den
Operationen Luftalarm und konnten unsere
Arbeit nicht unterbrechen zum Glück
haben wir Generatoren deshalb ist bei
uns das Licht noch nicht ausgegangen
Patienten an überlebenswichtigen Geräten
können sie nicht in den Bunker bringen
zum Schutz vor splitternden
Fensterscheiben werden ihre Betten in
die Gänge gerollt sobald die anderen in
den Schutzraum flüchten
alle im Bunker sind sind sie hier sicher
die Kinder haben sich daran gewöhnt für
sie ist es normal geworden
eine Normalität mitten in diesem
ukrainischen Kriegswinter
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter Heinz mit dem Blick auf die
deutsche Wirtschaft und zwar auf das
Handwerk die Handwerksbetriebe und deren
Beschäftigte stehen vor großen
Herausforderungen sagt der heute neu
gewählte Präsident des Zentralverbandes
des deutschen Handwerks Jörg Dietrich
wie steht's also um das Handwerk in
Deutschland weil er realer also dazu hat
sich auch noch ganz konkret noch
Präsident wollseifer beteiligt sagte das
ist derzeit für alle Handwerksbetriebe
generell schwierig sein noch rentabel zu
arbeiten besonders brenzlig könnte es im
Januar Februar werden weil die
energiepreisbremsen erst im März
rückwirkend gewährt würden außerdem sei
das Handwerk zunehmend von
auftragsrückgängen Stornierungen und
kauf Zurückhaltung betroffen die hören
Kosten an die Kunden weiterzugeben
schwierig für einige Firmen könnte es
finanziell eng werden laut einer
aktuellen Umfrage haben 20 Prozent der
Betriebe Zahlungsschwierigkeiten wegen
hoher Energiekosten und 15 Prozent
Liquiditätsprobleme
Lieferengpässe der künftige Präsident
Jörg Dittrich übernimmt also in
schwierigen Zeiten er will für bessere
Rahmenbedingungen streiten das Handwerk
sagt er ist der stabilisierende Kern
unserer Gesellschaft und Wirtschaft ein
großes Thema auf seiner Agenda der
Fachkräftemangel der ist riesig in den
Betrieben nach Angaben des Verbands
blieben zuletzt
250.000 Stellen unbesetzt Tendenz
steigend wenn erstmal die Babyboomer in
Rente gegangen sind eine Herkulesaufgabe
nicht nur fürs Handwerk bei realer
vielen Dank
nach der Trennung von Geschäftsführerin
Donato Hopfen hat die Deutsche Fußball
Liga eine neue Führung vorgestellt bis
zum kommenden Sommer sollen
interimsweise die Bundesliga Manager
Axel Helmert und Oliver Leki leiten wie
diefl-aufsichtsratschef Watzke bekannt
gab Watzke der auch
dfb-vizepräsident ist äußerte sich auch
zur Nationalmannschaft eine Trennung von
Bundestrainer Hansi Flick haben nie zur
Diskussion gestanden wichtig sei es nun
mit Blick auf die Heim em 2024 alle
Kräfte im deutschen Fußball zu bündeln
beim Biathlon Weltcup im
österreichischen Hochfilzen hat Denise
Herrmann Wick das sprindrennen gewonnen
die 33-Jährige blieb beim Schießen
fehlerfrei und verwies nach 7,5
Kilometern die Tschechien davidova und
die Französin Simon auf die Plätze 32
für das deutsche Biathlon Team weiß der
erste Saison Sieg
es begann mit dem Skandal um Harvey
Wayne Steam dem großen hollywood-modul
als aufgedeckt wurde was tatsächlich
hinter dem steht was gerne mal als
Besetzungscouch verharmlost wird nämlich
ein perfides und brutales System von
Gewalt Angst und Machtmissbrauch zwei
Reporterinnen der New York Times hatten
das damals recherchiert und
veröffentlicht und damit in der Folge
die weltweite me too Bewegung ausgelöst
einen Augenöffner
als diese Geschichte nun verfilmt she
Set läuft jetzt in den Kinos an Nadja
nasser hat den sich angesehen
New York 2017 ein Team von
Journalistinnen beschließt den Gerüchten
über sexuellen Missbrauch in der
Filmbranche nachzugehen hallo mein Name
ist Judy kentner ich bin im westlicher
Journalistin bei der New York Times
dabei stoßen die Reporterinnen immer
wieder auf einen Namen den des mächtigen
Hollywood-Produzenten Harvey weinansteen
womit genau haben wir es hier zu tun
jede dieser junge Frauen dachte er sein
unverbindliches geschäftliches Treffen
zu dem sie gehen würde stattdessen hat
er sie dann bedroht und sexuelle
Handlungen gefordert ich war jung
verängstigt hi hallo wir sind von der
New York Times sie haben mal für Harry
winsting gearbeitet richtig aber immer
wieder treffen sie auf eine Mauer des
Schweigens
ich
habe riesigen Respekt vor dieser Arbeit
welche runden muss man laufen welchen
Mut muss man haben an die Türen zu
klopfen und zu sagen entschuldigen Sie
vertrauen Sie mir bitte die schlimmste
Geschichte ihres Lebens an sie ist bei
mir in guten Händen
wie hast du die Frauen dazu gebracht dir
zu erzählen was ihnen passiert ist ich
glaube entscheidend war dass ich sagte
das was ihnen in der Vergangenheit
passiert ist kann ich nicht ändern aber
vielleicht können wir gemeinsam helfen
andere Menschen davor zu beschützen
lange war Weinstein einer der
erfolgreichsten Produzenten Hollywoods
er konnte Karrieren befördern oder
zerstören dutzende Frauen zwang er zu
sexuellen Handlungen darunter auch
berühmte Schauspielerinnen tatsächlich
ließen die Reporterinnen Meghan TUI und
Jodie Canter nicht nach bis sie endlich
Beweise fanden und Frauen die bereit
waren auszusagen
aber dieser Film zeigt wie wichtig vor
allem die mutigen Aussagen der eher
unbekannten Frauen im Umfeld von Winston
waren die für ihn gearbeitet hatten und
ihren Leben danach zerstört waren ich
fühlte diese große Scham
weil ich zuließ dass er mir das anthat
der Film she Set erzählt auf
eindrückliche Weise von der einfühlsamen
und schwierigen Recherchearbeit der
beiden Journalistinnen und vom großen
Leid der Betroffenen Frauen
es war als hätte er mir an diesem Tag
meine Stimme gestohlen
tatsächlich brachte der Fall wine Steen
immer mehr Frauen dazu ihre Stimme gegen
Missbrauch zu erheben die metoo-bewegung
wurde zum weltweiten Phänomen gegen
Harvey Weinstein laufen mehrere Prozesse
im drohen jahrzehntelange Haftstrafen
die Lehre aus unserer Geschichte und
jetzt auch aus diesem Film ist das ist
manchmal nur ganz wenige Menschen
braucht um unglaubliche Veränderungen zu
bewirken wir sind alle da
habt ihr gesprochen she said ist ein
großartiger Film spannend und berührend
beleuchtet er die Geschichten der Frauen
die mit ihrem Mut die Welt verändert
haben
das war es im heute journal weiter
geht's gleich bei Maybrit Illner die mit
ihren Gästen über den Kriegsverlauf von
der Ukraine spricht und um 0:45 Uhr
meldet sich dann wohl schmiese mit
unserem hessischen Update und wir melden
uns morgen wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter wir schauen zurück
auf den Herbst und es war der dritt
wärmste Herbst in Europa und auch in
Deutschland wir sehen hier hauptsächlich
rötliche Töne Hotspot der Erhitzung war
Spitzbergen oder noch heftiger Grönland
man sieht hier eine enorme
Temperaturabweichung ja in diesem
vergangenen Herbst schauen wir auf die
aktuelle Wetterlage und da haben wir es
mit diesem Tief zu tun das bringt Kälte
und auch Schnee in den nächsten Tagen es
zieht über das Mittelmeer weiter nach
Norden und zapft die kalte Luft hier an
und so gibt es Schneefall hauptsächlich
im Süden und im Osten Deutschlands schau
mal auf die kommende Nacht und da kommt
im Südwesten Schnee auf der Schnee im
Osten Deutschlands verabschiedet sich
dazwischen klares teilweise auf es
bildet sich Nebel glatt wird es so oder
so auf den Straßen einmal durch
Schneefall oder über befriedene Nässe
denn die Temperaturen gehen zurück bis
auf -6° Schleswig-Holstein sonst
zwischen -4 und 0 und ganz im Westen bei
plus 1 Grad morgen dann weitere
Schneefälle ganz im Süden ansonsten aber
bleibt es trocken im Osten ist es dicht
bewölkt nach Westen in zeigt sich die
Sonne häufiger und auch etwas länger und
die Temperaturen steigen auf -1 bis +4
Grad es wird also ein kalter Tag die
nächsten Tage weiterer Schneefall im
Süden und im Osten Samstag - 2 bis plus
3 Grad und Sonntag ja da waren dann die
Schneewolken nach Norden und Montag
sogar dann wieder zurück nach Westen und
damit ein schöner Abend